what's up guys it's me hi and welcome to
another video no wha no everybody no wha
[Music]
leave your entries in the sir really
close let's just jump into it guys let's
jump into it first of all keep
subscribing god dammit
have I not said this before have I not
told you guys there's I don't know if
you know about this there's a thing
going on me versus T series this Indian
channel is taking over it's crazy like
where did they come from
out of nowhere we gotta make it to 100
we got it we're gonna make it to a
hundred mill and then we're gonna dab on
them and that's how we know we're in it
keep subscribing or else you will be
sorry let's review this week's the why
everyone YouTube's favorite show that's
right god damn this better is absolutely
incredible Jesus Christ we have a launch
and carrying dead Felix and oh that is
the most incredible goddamn what's it
what's the artist
we're not a Vincent goddamn now that's
doing your part I want to print it is
that's so sick camera quality of 77 year
old man with 137 subscribership camera
quality of the richest and most
subscribed youtuber all right I'll let
you in on a little secret it's not me
who messes up the camera quality it's my
editor and I know my editor sitting
there I don't know Brad or side go an
earlier to look look at this do you see
this high quality camera that I have
right here you can't see it right maybe
you can see it for a second I'm not
joking that I have lutely
I know it seems like I'm like but I have
this high quality
but anytime I send over the footage it
looks like garbage hello everyone it's
me Aluna larionova I genuinely have no
idea how he manages to make the footage
look so bad when I look over here is the
information on his video quality
it's an MPEG movie it's 10 AE frame rate
of 30 there's nothing here so it's
technically wrong it's only 1 point 4 9
gigabytes for about 25 minutes of
footage I am recording on a webcam at
720p through OBS it's the same process
that he uses and yet my quality looks
like that and his looks like that so
it's not me and it's not scythe I don't
know how he does it and after 5 years
I've stopped trying to figure out what
he's doing over there I just take the
footage and go that's what he's given me
and I edit it into something thanks bye
we should all subscribe to Marcia and
give 10 million diamond play blood as a
wedding gift to her firm 9 year-old
army that is so sweet I think it's not
the camera
it's just peer to himself it's not in HD
this is what I'm talking about
it's not the camera I care about quality
guys it's one of my most important
aspects of the video I say if the camera
quality is not good enough we cut the
whole thing I always say that in my
editor testimony please thank you
9 year old in a normal video 9 year old
when Marcia is in a video is it me or is
none of these people 9 hey I'm just
saying Elon Musk is lurking in this very
subreddit everyone say hi Ellen Ellen
are you there give us a hint give us a
call
maybe host meme review or something like
that
I made an infirmity
[Music]
[Music]
YouTube's favorite show ever that's
amazing grapefruit push better than my
own editors hello everyone it's me again
I've already forcibly injected myself
into the video once I might as well do
it again
fun story when he did that first meme
review I thought it was just gonna be
that one video I didn't know it was
gonna be the like most famous series of
all time and the best most highly rated
YouTube series ever and so I just did
that thinking that's good enough
oopsie PewDiePie shopping at B and Q
that's right
nice meeting you James for the Zedd very
nice I met a lot of other people there
and I always get the same question what
are you doing here
why are you here Oh same reason you are
here I have to go outside sometimes I
know it's crazy
I don't just exist as a metaphysical
being inside of YouTube video if t
series surpasses pewdiepie he will no
longer be YouTube's most subscribed
channel however he will still be the
most subscribed creator most subscribed
me a reviewer mo subscribe fortnight
streamer for subscribe book review
most of my Swedish youtuber most
subscribed to new source most subscribed
child reviewer most subscribed comedian
mo subscribe millionaire most subscribed
to minecraft streamer that one I'm very
proud of mo subscribe to meme compiler
what the hell does that mean
most subscribed to movie reviewer end I
mean I appreciate it thank you very much
but this is the kind of language of
someone admitting defeat
there will be no brofist for this
episode for this kind of attitude I know
it might seem a little harsh because
this is a heartfelt genuine message but
I cannot condone this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] of attitude alright I don't want
to say that word but that's what you are
we either win it or we die
that's how life works Sun Tzu's said
himself the general warlord anyone
fighting to the death will fight ten
times stronger and that's what we're
doing here none of this book precomposed
losing strategy I don't think so
not on my watch and therefore I retract
any brofist
that I have previously given that's
right I bet you didn't know I had this
power but at any given moment I can give
and I can take and I take away brofist
just like that
I take of them away from you and I don't
care about the tears because we have a
mission we have something to work ok
nothing else makes me god damn it what
video did you make this week that you're
proud of share below the one you do my
remember when demonetised was in a thick
petition to make sponsor eagle sound
play when peers there's ads in his
videos hashtag bring back sponsor eagle
sponsor eagle is not just your taxi
delivery service ok
he's not just some plot device to save
us in the last minute like Lord of the
Rings ok he will come back when he's so
damn pleases when you get 25,000 up
votes but don't get featured on meme
your review or the white what's that
original design Baikal shoes I changed
up some things tell me what you guys
think should this be the new upvote
design it looks like they've already
implemented very well the people have
spoken
I love democracy you've seen gold Brad
now I present mrs. B's what the hell is
that I will not stand for this
cyberbullying where are my pants I can
still wear pants ok even if I don't have
legs I can still wear them this is the
kind of discriminatory nature that makes
me reflect brofist pewdiepie vs t series
checking for it what
it's awesome we've now taking it one
step further printer hacks now
billboards pay checkerboard so gap gets
below ten kick nine-year-olds for
laptops if you're not sitting on four
laptops making new accounts and
subscribing which I don't condone by the
way because I would be cheating but if
you're not doing that I will be very
upset
no needs no weeks part fanart oh my god
there's no knees in this picture this is
how it looks like if you mean hey I love
that bad art by the way that's awesome I
thought this was my recipe to you
because the camera quality was over 36 P
360 P mu take talk didn't oopsies why
we'd spend a while since Gloria Borger
burger has been around huh find 5.7
million for illegally collecting kids
data you know tick-tock all you gotta do
is hit up the sponsor ego and this could
all go away
I can tell Gloria I can go right now and
tell her yo we're not doing this
Oh God what are you laughing about me
nothing my brain Felix Kjellberg oh god
I didn't see it shout out to metro for
being one of the only pro QT pie news
sites
Phillip is unlikely rise to the top from
minecraft and brofist to TV series and
making YouTube history that's nice let's
show that we support fine journalism
isn't creating alternate accounts to
subscribe to PD by the same concept as
the TV series using bought well yes
but actually no bail Delphine happy low
you're in PD pipes video I
can't believe he gave me $0 honestly the
best share of dollars of my life
Thank You Belle Delphine I mean you're
welcome well Delphine very cool
he took down Pokemon go he took down PT
pay these mega stuf 64 it's our last
hope
yes a joke that was funny three years
ago he's a healthy this animation took
me three months so all I want is for you
to see it my final attempt posting in
this here thanks for sorting by me what
is that a drone oh it's like a I was
going to be a fight
is that it oh my god sixty nine nine
[Applause]
that's a pretty good motto no what is it
I don't know yeah damn that looks legit
where's the GPO you know they've been
working on this for three months six I'm
drinking monsters haha Wow they spend a
considerable amount of time with it
audience yeah dad
[Music]
damn cool
very nice
aha
damn to get all the mono that's why it
looked so legit
[Music]
thank you Kevin never sleep you can't
lead to an amazing job well done when
you see pity pipe in real life I want to
shake you that was actually the footage
that's who we wanted to shake bad with
JK Rowling reveals that you the reader
for kaolin long what how did she know
that that's great well it means this
week are fantastic it's really much here
huge Allah pity okay stop all right stop
stop that's it for this week's Lou I
hope you guys enjoyed smash like thank
you for all the submissions this has
been a really good week I feel like so
here we go we get a brofist to burst
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame crania drop the
crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys leg